[Music]
yeah I said what I said thanks to
Tik Tok hormone girlies showing off
their before and after shots of their
tatas claiming that taking just a
teaspoon of Bolen will increase their
bus size but is this legit well what we
know is that Bolen contains
phytoestrogens which can bind to
estrogen receptors in the body like
breast tissue hypothetically stimulating
growth but does it actually
work probably not we don't have any
randomized control trials yet looking at
B pollen for boobs but a study of
multiple different B species found that
pollen didn't even interact with
estrogen receptors in a lab model
there's also way better sources of
phytoestrogens in the diet so things
like soy for example is a very rich dose
and one that you would likely be
consuming in much greater quantity than
a teeny tiny spoonful of expensive
pollen and we look at research on
phytoestrin supplementation that was
actually marketed for natural breast
enhancement they found no evidence that
it actually worked even at doses that
were 250 times higher than recommended